[Musique]
nos exportations d'armes font donc vivre
quelques 165
000 salariés en France un commerce de
quelques 17 milliards d'euros mais
l'enquête que nous venons de voir
réaliser par la journaliste Anne Poiret
nous démontre s'il le fallait à quel
point il s'avère difficile de percer les
secrets de ses ventes de mieux contrôler
l'utilisation de ces armes par ceux qui
nous les achètent peut-on espérer
changer la donne nous allons en débattre
maintenant en compagnie de nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
Eric biegala pour commencer bienvenue
vous êtes grand porteur à la rédaction
internationale de Radio France où vous
êtes spécialiste des questions de
défense vous avez été aussi
correspondante guerre vous connaissez
bien le terrain en plus de bien
connaître le marché et cette non
transparence démontrée dans ce film que
nous venons de voir à l'instant Aymeric
est loin bienvenue vous êtes également
avec nous vous êtes responsable du
plaidoyer armes au sein de l'ONG Amnesty
internationale France et
nous avons d'ailleurs vu un témoigner
dans ce documentaire vous êtes l'auteur
de vente d'armes une honte française
coécrit avec Sébastien Fontanel et un
ouvrage est disponible aux éditions le
passager clandestin vous écrivez
notamment dans votre ouvrage depuis plus
de 50 ans faisant fille de ses
engagements au profit de ses intérêts
économiques le pays des droits de
l'homme arme des régimes qui les
bafouent ouvertement on en parlera bien
évidemment ensemble sur ce plateau puis
enfin avec nous Jacques maire bienvenue
vous êtes ancien député en marche des
Hauts-de-Seine et aujourd'hui président
de la cofre ex c'est la Compagnie
française des expositions vous êtes le
commissaire général du pavillon français
à
Osaka où se déroulera l'Exposition
Universelle ça sera en 2025 et vous avez
été en 2020
l'auteur d'un rapport concernant
justement ces ventes d'armes plus
exactement co-auteur puisque ce rapport
vous l'avez rédigé avec la députée les
républicains Michel Le Tabarro c'est un
rapport qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre on va évidemment en reparler
ensemble sur ce plateau dans un instant
pour bien comprendre et peut-être
réactualiser ce film que nous venons de
voir qui date maintenant de 5 ans voici
quelques chiffres réactualisés tout
d'abord des plus gros exportateurs
d'armes dans le monde
les États-Unis arrivent très largement
en tête avec 40% de part de marché la
Russie arrive en deuxième position et la
France est arrivée en troisième position
elle a longtemps été la troisième
vendeuse d'armes dans les années 70 et
puis elle est redevenue et on l'a
découvert dans ce documentaire la
troisième vendeuse d'armes dans le monde
depuis le quinquennat de François
Hollande les sources de ce graphique
sont à trouver à l'Institut
International de la recherche sur la
paix de Stockholm qui fait foi en
matière de vente d'armes dans le monde
et puis cette fois les les plus gros
importateurs d'armes ce qui achètent ces
armes et là dans le top 3 nous trouvons
l'Inde l'Arabie saoudite le
Qatar c'est sur la période 2018-2022 et
en réalité ce graphique que vous
découvrez que vous découvrez n'est pas
tout à fait à jour puisque aujourd'hui
le 3e importateur d'armes au monde et
l'Ukraine et ce depuis la guerre qui se
déroule entre l'Ukraine d'une part et
bien sûr la Russie est-ce que cette
guerre en Ukraine à chambouler ce marché
des ventes d'armes pour commencer et
remettre à jour le film que nous venons
de voir alors oui et non non parce que
on parle d'importation d'armes
effectivement l'Ukraine importe
massivement des armes mais les achètent
pas forcément il y a eu beaucoup de dons
il y a eu beaucoup de matériels qui ont
été cédés comme ça à la va-vite les les
Polonais par exemple ont envoyé en
Ukraine de 250 chars et 72 qui étaient
des restes on va dire de l'Armada
soviétique qui existait qui a existé
dans les années 70-80 et qui était
toujours en train de sécher sur des
parkings mais qui fonctionnaient et donc
c'est massif un an et demi plus tard on
parle d'envoyer des léopards des
léopards
qui sont de fabrication allemande mais
c'est pas du tout dans ses proportions
là on est dans peut-être une centaine
après il y a des certains pays l'Union
européenne ont mis en place des des
fonds alloués à l'Ukraine grâce auquel
l'Ukraine va pouvoir s'alimenter acheter
là pour le coup mais avec de l'argent en
France on a 200 millions d'euros qui
sont qui sont sécurisés pour que
l'Ukraine puisse acheter du matériel
français alors ça va être un radar ça va
être des systèmes de de pont de pont de
terrain qui puisse qui peuvent faire
passer des chars ou
ce qui est très important pour l'Ukraine
surtout sur les terrains sur lesquels
son armée évolue actuellement donc ce
qu'on appelle les j'allais dire les
bas-fonds c'est pas les bas-fonds c'est
sont les les en fait toute la plaine qui
est en aval du Nièvre côté
Ukraine là il y a plein de cours d'eau
qui sont des affluents il va falloir les
passer séminer les ponts des explosé les
Russes ont barré tout ça il va falloir
construire des ponts ou faire des mettre
en place des plombs flottants etc non
par exemple ça c'est un des matériels
que l'Ukraine a acheté à la France mais
avec de l'argent français alors
évidemment Aymeric est loin la question
qu'on se pose c'est ce que ces armes
vendues notamment par la France mais pas
seulement est-ce qu'elles sont vendues
en toute légalité
à l'Ukraine à vos yeux alors il y a pas
de problème de conscience là si alors il
y a deux choses il y a la question
morale et la question juridique
sur la question morale à chacun de se
faire son avis en tout cas l'Ukraine
répond à une agression caractérisée un
crime d'agression commis par la Russie
contre son territoire contre sa
population donc
l'Ukraine est en situation de défense
donc elle a le droit de s'armer après il
y a deux dimensions dans laquelle nous
avons le droit de l'armée et nous avons
le droit de l'armée après il y a deux
dimensions dans votre question
au-delà de l'aspect politique morale il
y a cet aspect juridique qu'il y ait au
fait de savoir si les transferts d'armes
peuvent être considérés l'égo
il verra deux situations il va y avoir
premièrement le respect de l'embargo qui
était mis en place par l'Union
européenne l'ensemble de le pack de
sanction parce que c'est un véritable
pack de sanction qui a été mis en place
par l'Union européenne depuis l'invasion
de la Crimée en 2014 et qui depuis est
sans cesse ren français donc aujourd'hui
il est formellement interdit à partir
des États membres de l'Union européenne
d'exporter des armes ou des biens un
doux d'usage à destination de la Russie
ça c'est le premier élément et après il
y a le second élément qui qui
consisterait à se poser la question de
savoir dans quelles conditions sont
réalisées ces transferts est-ce que par
exemple
toutes les conditions ont été
réunies et données garantie donnée par
les Ukrainiens sur
la question du détournement et du risque
de détournement des armes et notamment
on pense aux armes légères et petits
cailloux alors c'est une situation c'est
une question qui est compliquée parce
qu'on parle d'un pays en guerre et que
dans un pays en guerre réunir toutes les
conditions liées à la sécurisation des
stocks par exemple à l'entreposage des
armes dans de bonnes conditions avec des
systèmes de registres c'est un peu
compliqué mais il charge aux États
exportateurs de s'assurer que les armes
qui sont transférées sont pas destinées
à circuler librement sans contrôle sur
le territoire même si on est en train de
conflit d'ailleurs les Ukrainiens ont
créé une commission spéciale en juillet
dernier destiné une commission Haddock
destinée à donner des garanties aux
États exportateurs concernant la gestion
des stocks d'armes qu'ils ont reçu de la
part des États exportateurs on va
revenir à au documentaire que nous de
voir avec un tout petit extrait c'est
François Hollande qui justifie les
ventes d'armes sous son quinquennat et
on en reparle juste après chaque maire
il y a certains qui nous disent mais
est-ce qu'il faut exporter les armes
c'est un sujet que je
comprends est-ce que c'est bien d'être
rôle de vendre des armes oui c'est notre
rôle parce que si nous ne vendons pas un
certain nombre de matériel
le risque c'est que d'autres le fasse à
notre place
[Musique]
pas du tout le marché
alors sur cette mission parlementaire
elle intervient en 2020 autrement dit
deux ans après la réalisation du
documentaire que nous venons de voir
son origine en fait c'est une petite
quelle est l'origine oui c'est une
petite crise interne à la majorité en
fait pour dire la vérité puisque
beaucoup de parlementaires notamment de
la Commission à faire étrangères et
défense en 2017 2018 était très ému par
les critiques qui étaient je dirais
adressées à l'exécutif français
concernant les exportations d'armes aux
Émirats et en Arabie Saoudite
qui ne se comportait pas bien dans la
guerre au Yémen et là on rejoint très
clairement le documentaire et ce qui a
été fait c'est qu'effectivement on a
fait cette commission cette mission
d'information parlementaire
pour dépasser le cas du Yémen et pour
venir avoir une portée plus importante
plus stratégique et de plus long terme
sur finalement
se faire donner une conviction au niveau
parlementaire sur l'efficacité et la
légitimité en fait du système de
contrôle des armements est-ce que oui ou
non on fait bien les choses est-ce que
oui ou non ce contrôle est perçu comme
efficace et légitime et est-ce qu'il
doit faire face à de nombreux défis et
c'est ce travail qui nous a mené pendant
deux ans et qui a donné lieu à des
préconisations et un très grand débat
avec l'exécutif bien sûr alors quand je
disais tout à l'heure ce vous
conclusions et vous propositions on fait
couler pas mal d'encre à l'époque et
voilà ce qui était finalement les
principales proposions la proposition
choc c'était la création d'une
délégation parlementaire dédiée au
contrôle des vendarmes
sur le même modèle d'ailleurs d'une
délégation parlementaire qui existe et
qui a été mise en place concernant cette
fois le renseignement
et alors vous proposiez que
des élus soient huit députés et huit
sénateurs composent cette délégation
parlementaire et selon votre rapport ses
élus auraient été habilités secrets
défense aurait pu effectuer un contrôle
a posteriori sur les exportations
d'armement alors ne participerait pas au
fameux aux fameuses commissions à terme
ministérielle pour l'étude des
exportations de matériels de guerre le
ci2e MG qu'on a bien décrit dans le film
que nous venons de voir qui a la
haute-main sur ses ventes avec les
représentants du ministère des armées
des Affaires étrangères de Bercy de
Matignon et des services de
renseignements mais selon votre
proposition il aurait pu cette
délégation aurait pu consulter ses
licences aussi les avis rendus par cette
fameuse commission auditionner des
membres du gouvernement ou de
l'administration et creuser telle ou tel
sujet ça c'était la proposition phare
c'était la de votre première des deux
propositions phares vous allez me parler
de la deuxième mais sur celle-là force
est de constater que quelques années
après elle n'a pas été mise en place
alors premièrement cette délégation
parlementaire je vous exprimez c'est
plutôt la solution cible c'est à dire à
terme il faut une dég parlementaire on
proposait dans un premier temps de créer
en fait un esprit de collaboration
exécutif légitime qui n'existe pas à
travers un groupe de travail et à
travers une dispositif informel pourquoi
parce que il faut convaincre toutes les
parties prenantes on est dans un deeps
on est dans une situation dans lequel
les gens n'ont pas l'habitude de
s'ouvrir l'extérieur et là les
parlementaires ont un intérêt très fort
c'est que ils ont un point de vue
indépendant donc ils doivent pas ils
doivent pas être mêlés à la décision
d'autorisation mais ils doivent pouvoir
la critiquer et soumettre les
problématiques qu'elle crée sur tel ou
tel sujet technologique ou conflits au
niveau de plus haut de l'exécutif alors
attendez trois ans après cette
proposition la remise de ce rapport elle
constate là
cette délégation j'imagine que la faute
en fait parce que le gouvernement à
l'été 2021 sous la signature de Jean
Castex
a pris un décret autorisant le lancement
de ce groupe de travail entre le
législatif et exécutif d'accord ce
décret était publié et il revenait en
fait au Parlement à se saisir de la
balle au bon il a commencé le travail et
ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que même
si l'exécutif a fait ce pas en avant et
ben à ce stade le Parlement à la fois
assemblé et Sénat n'a pas engagé les
travaux donc en fait autrement dit ni
Richard Ferrand président de l'Assemblée
nationale ni Gérard Larcher n'ont trouvé
un accord pour mettre en place cette
déléguer c'est un peu paradoxal parce
que c'est très paradoxal parce que si
effectivement à un moment donné c'est
l'exécutif qui fait le premier pas en
réponse un rapport parlementaire ce qui
est assez rare qu'est-ce qui fait qu'à
un moment donné la balle n'est pas
saisie au bon par l'Assemblée et ça
c'est quelque chose que je trouve un peu
dommage c'est vrai que c'est plus
compliqué aujourd'hui qu'en 2017 2022
parce que le spectre politique inclut en
gros des partis politiques qui sont
probablement fondamentalement non
alignés par rapport à cette politique je
pense en particulier au R et les filles
donc les conditions sont plus difficiles
maintenant mais je pense que c'est quand
même un besoin assez fort et je suis
heureux que ce débat puisse progresser
par exemple à l'occasion de la LPM on
reparlera de la deuxième proposition
forte de ce rapport je voudrais
simplement
que vous fassiez un commentaire sur ce
qui a été peut-être le travail de cette
commission c'est conclusions et puis la
non mise en place de cette fameuse
délégation parlementaire notamment Corée
sans doute contribuer à mettre davantage
de transparence ces ventes et c'est tout
le problème démontré par ce documentaire
en France on a une vraie difficulté
vis-à-vis de la transparence dans le
domaine des transferts d'armes et
vis-à-vis de la question du contrôle
parlementaire c'est un peu
consubstantiel à la Cinquième République
à son fonctionnement gaulien le rapport
de Jacques maire et Michel Tamaro
faisait partie fait partie des meilleurs
rapports qui ont été produits sur le
sujet nous nous avons retrouvé
énormément de recommandations d'Amnesty
International sur le sujet et des autres
ONG qui travaillent sur le sujet
globalement oui parce que c'est une
avancée c'est la première fois que nous
avions des parlementaires qui proposait
la création d'une délégation
parlementaire dédiée à cette question là
après je pense que dans le
fonctionnement des institutions au sein
du Parlement vous avez aussi déblocages
en termes de fonctionnement sur
d'alignement entre la commission
d'affaires étrangères et la commission
de la défense qui n'ont pas forcément
une appréhension du problème
identique chacun étant qu'en pensant sur
des positions un peu différentes et puis
le rôle du Sénat est un peu aparmé pour
que nos spectateurs comprennent ce qui
est en train de se passer en ce moment
même dans le cas de la haute
programmation militaire l'idée du
rapport Jacques maire et Michel Tabarro
continue à prospérer alors au sein de
l'ordre de la première en première
lecture l'Assemblée nationale il a été
proposé la création d'une délégation
parlementaire sur le modèle du rapport
jacquemer Michel Tabarro ça a été botté
en touche le gouvernement refusé et la
plupart des parlementaires ne l'ont pas
voté au Sénat
le président de la commission d'affaires
étrangères et de la défense Christian
Cambon a proposé un amendement qui a été
adopté proposant des temps de le champ
de manoeuvre de la délégation
renseignement en lui attribuant la
capacité de contrôler les ventes sachant
que on l'a dit dans ce débat la
délégation renseignement travaille sur
le saut du secret défense le
gouvernement Sébastien les Cornu le
Cornu ministre des armées a eu un seul
mot avis défavorable
donc on est même sous le saut du secret
défense dans l'incapacité d'avoir un
gouvernement capable de lâcher la bride
et de dire on va se confronter avec les
parlementaires répondre à leurs
questions et créer ce phénomène de
collaboration et peut-être ce nouveau
rapport de force nouveau rendre compte
et finalement ces deux entités le
gouvernement et le Parlement n'ont pas
l'habitude de travailler sur le sujet et
je termine là-dessus sur les biens
d'usage le contrôle des biens d'où
l'usage je voulais juste avoir votre
avis sur cette question et sur cette
omerta qui nous est décrite dans ce
documentaire confirmer d'une certaine
manière
par Jacques maire à l'instant par
vous-même concernant ce contrôle des
ventes d'armes alors dans notre pays et
la bonne manière de le faire j'irai un
petit peu même au-delà j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a une il y a une mentalité
française qui fait que on a
une administration pas simplement une
administration militaire mais
l'administration générale qui est avare
dans l'information vous savez depuis
1976 je crois qu'il y a une loi qui dit
explicitement sauf avis contraire donc
sauf secret défense tout document
administratif est public comment se
fait-il que nous journalistes soyons
encore en train de voir passer par une
commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs pour pouvoir avoir des
documents administratifs qui normalement
sont publiques bon c'est comme ça un
autre exemple il y a quelques années
Michel peut-être parce qu'on touche un
domaine ultra-sensible que cela oui
vendeur mais quand on touche au domaine
de l'hôpital par exemple syst
automatiquement je sais plus je crois
que c'est la même chose ouais c'est la
même chose pour avoir en fait les
chiffres de des hôpitaux publics etc bah
faut passer par une commission d'accès
aux documents administratifs alors ça
fait un numéro spécial du point tous les
ans je crois sur
comment soigne les hôpitaux enfin
revenons-en au vendeur parce que le
journaliste que vous êtes il a besoin
d'information il a besoin d'avoir des
chiffres exacts qu'il a besoin d'avoir
des des références vous les obtenez ou
les sources lorsqu'il est question des
vendarmes françaises par exemple de
temps en temps on a des gens qui lâchent
un truc un peu plus tard que il y a
quelques heures quelqu'un m'a donné le
chiffre de la vente de 36 rafales
à l'Inde 8 milliards bon
à ma connaissance il était pas c'était
pas vraiment public alors dans 8
milliards est-ce qu'il y a aussi
l'armement qui va avec etc c'est
on parlait de l'Ukraine là tout à
l'heure l'Ukraine n'a absolument compté
en rien sur les chiffres records qui a
fait MDA qui est le premier fabricant de
missiles français qui a été un chiffre
au corps en 2022 tout simplement parce
qu'en fait tous les missiles qu'il a
vendu ce sont les missiles qui vont à
l'équiper les rafales qu'on a vendu aux
Émirats rapuni rendu énormément de
Rafale mais il y a tout l'armement qui
va avec donc et donc ça ça fait
finalement des chiffres qui peuvent être
absolument énormes mais il faut bien
voir que ça ça tient compte non
seulement des appareils comme si on
parle des avions de l'armement de tout
ce qui est le maintien en condition
opérationnelles de tout ce qui est de la
chaîne logistique de réparation qui qui
va aller avec pour pouvoir avoir en
disponibilité c'est ces avions et puis
en général on a aussi une
l'oeil qui porte un petit peu plus loin
on se dit avec tout ça avec toute cette
chaîne logistique etc on va pouvoir
peut-être en revendre davantage
Jacques mais vous avez vu une deuxième
proposition forte de votre rapport c'est
peut-être le moment d'en parler parce
que vous dites là ça nous concerne tous
oui juste pour la première il y a une
grande ambiguïté en fait sur plus de
temps de transparence pourquoi faire
quand le Parlement veut dire quand on
s'implique c'est pas pour une
transparence qui permet d'augmenter les
contentieux juridiques contre les tas ou
les exportateurs c'est pour faire en
sorte de renforcer la légitimité le
contrôle et la sécurité des exportations
et c'est pour ça que finalement l'état
des industriels ont peur c'est qu'ils se
disent cette transparence finalement au
bout du bout si elle nous amène au
tribunal on n'a pas envie donc nous on
comprend bien ça et on pense que de ce
point de vue le Parlement peut offrir
des garanties tout en maintenant
certains secrets vers qui qui diminue le
risque le risque politique et le risque
en matière de droits humains et qui se
dit ne fragilise pas complètement la
capacité de décider de l'État ça c'est
un premier élément deuxième proposition
très importante pour nous c'est les
biens à double usage alors ça faut
expliquer voilà les biens à double usage
qui peuvent être à la fois civils et
militaires alors je prends un petit
exemple vous l'avez vu exploser dans la
guerre en Ukraine aujourd'hui on reprend
des robots et des drones qui sont des
jouets pour en faire des bombardiers je
dirais improviser pour aller taper sur
des colonnes ou sur des choses qui sont
encore plus importantes dans les biens
d'oublage c'est tout ce qui sont les
technologies d'interception et
d'analyses des communications et qui
permettent par exemple en Chine ou
ailleurs ou même en Egypte de faire du
ciblage des populations uniquement par
rapport à leurs opinions religieuses
politiques vis-à-vis des opposants voilà
au régime en place voilà et ça c'est
problématique parce que depuis toujours
c'est bien double usage ont été moins
contrôlés bien sûr mais ils ont été
aussi contrôlés sur un plan strictement
administratif et ce que nous avons
demandé dans notre rapport et là ça a
été vraiment suivi des faits c'est qu'on
augmente le contrôle politique sur ces
biens d'eau d'usage qu'on soit beaucoup
plus attentif y compris sur le plan
technologique et qu'on rende c'est bien
de l'usage je après plus transparent
avec un rapport au Parlement et avec un
meilleur contrôle de Matignon et pour
revenir sur la transparence la
transparence à une fin en soi pour
l'opinion publique la société civile les
médias c'est de s'assurer que la France
respecte ces engagements internationaux
les engagements internationaux c'est le
parent le traité sur commère des armes
c'est le grand traité que la France a
promu à adopté signé négocier ratifier
et qui
impose à la France de ne pas exporter
d'armes quand il y a un risque ces armes
puissent servir à commettre des
violations des droits humains lui rendre
international militaires a été mis en
place en 2014
le plus grand vendeur d'animaux au monde
on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure en
graphique les États-Unis n'ont toujours
pas ils l'ont signés
[Musique]
un petit moment déjà mais à l'époque
Trump avait déclaré qu'il retirait la
signature du traité comme si retirait
une signature
au moment où il a été tourné machine
n'avait pas encore signé visiblement
2018 John Kerry c'est John Kerry qui l'a
signé la Chine et la Russie qui sont
aussi des vendeurs
d'accord la Chine est à partir
donc tout ça pour les finalement la
transparence elle est au service
de l'opinion publique du citoyen
français comprend à qui on exporte
pourquoi faire et dans quelles
conditions et d'où le besoin d'avoir
accès à des informations et de mobiliser
les parlementaires qui ne sont pas
mobilisés et notamment sur la question
est d'où l'usage des biens d'oubliable
c'est bien un doublage
pose un véritable problème et on le voit
dans le cadre du conflit ukrainien
puisque vous avez des médias régionaux
l'Observatoire des armements ou le
Nouvel Obs il y a pas très longtemps qui
ont révélé des affaires ou visiblement
des biens à double usage français des
composants seraient transférés encore
jusqu'en 2022 au moins à la Russie pour
équiper des drones donc on a une
difficulté avec ces équipements c'est
composant qui parfois sont de la d'une
puce mais qui ont des capacités
militaires considérables ce sont des
biens d'abord civils qui peuvent avoir
une utilisation militaire là où je suis
en désaccord avec Jacques maire c'est
que le rapport le nouveau rapport qui
était voulu par Jean Castex sur les
biensage il fait il est encore moins
dense que le rapport aux exportations
sur les matériels de guerre et le
premier et quelques feuilles oui je suis
d'accord c'est un début quelques mais
qui est bien en deçà de ce que prévoit
en termes de volonté politique les
rédacteurs de l'Union européenne qui
voulaient que au travers de la
transparence sur les BMW usage on met
particulièrement en avant la question de
ces technologies de surveillance comme
amesis en Libye qui ont permis de cibler
des opinions publiques et des défenseurs
des droits humains donc que cette
volonté politique de lutter contre ses
biens et leur diffusion apparaissent
dans le rapport sur les biens de l'usage
alors si la tête le moment d'ouvenir un
tout petit peu les fenêtres et de
regarder chez nos voisins européens
notamment parce qu'il y a aussi des
engagements sur ces questions au niveau
des
27 aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
vous en dire si on compare ce qui se
passe ce manque de transparence constaté
encore une fois dans ce film
et par nos deux autres interlocuteurs
sur ce plateau si on compare cette
situation à celle qu'on peut vivre en
Grande-Bretagne par exemple d'être
montré un exemple en matière de de
contrôle de Vandamme qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire on est on est en dessous de
d'un certain nombre de pays en européens
en termes de transparence sur le sujet
oui de toute façon mais je pense que
c'est plus une culture on est plus sur
une culture de
on reste très très réservé quand tous
les pays européens se disent moi je vais
des l'Ukraine en lui donnant ceci en lui
donnant cela la France dit bah nous
aussi on va aider et puis on va donner
on vous dira pas quoi et puis ça dure
pendant des semaines et puis
m'en donne beaucoup
dites-nous quoi oui ben on peut pas si
on peut le dire enfin bon c'est ça avec
l'état-major ça a toujours été comme ça
c'est c'est compliqué et l'occasion de
de fréquenter d'autres États majeurs du
côté britannique alors il y a des choses
qui sont ouvertes après il y a des il y
a des politiques en Europe qui ont été
qui ont été très très différentes
pensaient que l'Allemagne par exemple
pendant des années et jusqu'à ces
derniers mois avaient des politiques
extrêmement restrictives pour tout ce
qui était exportation de ces matériels
qu'elle pouvait fabriquer ce qui fait
que par exemple qu'une arme comme le
Milan c'est un missile d'épaule
anti-char qui est une coopération
franco-allemande a pas pu être beaucoup
beaucoup exporté puisque les Allemands
en fait s'opposaient à toute exportation
les Français étaient tout à fait
d'accord pour pouvoir en exporter ici là
où est ailleurs mais les Allemands
disaient stop là on va pas pareil pour
les Suédois les Suédois qui est une
nation qui était jusqu'à très récemment
enfin qui n'est pas encore dans l'OTAN
mais qui était un peu sur la réserve qui
était plutôt neutre etc mais qui
fabriquait énormément d'armements ils
ont beaucoup de avaient aussi
pareillement des des politiques
publiques d'exportation qui était très
très restrictives on vend pas un apport
qui on vend pas n'importe comment etc on
est en train on est en train de changer
un petit peu alors en Allemagne c'est
clair c'est on est en train de vraiment
de de virer complètement sa cultive mais
vous avez encore des certains pays comme
la Suisse par exemple ensuite il est
absolument hors de question que
l'Allemagne puisse exporter des
matériels qui ont des composants suisses
à l'intérieur y compris à l'Ukraine bon
chaque merde j'imagine que dans le cadre
de ce travail parlementaire de cette
mission vous avez scanné un petit peu ce
qui se passe autour il y a des bons
exemples à suivre il y a pas d'exemple
parfait il y a des gens qui font plus je
prends l'exemple du Royaume-Uni ils font
plus même s'ils effectivement
établissement de militaire française
n'existait pas le cas ils font plus mais
ils font le plus de façon assez
tactique inégale temporaire c'est plutôt
lié à des performances en fait de
parlementaires qui à un moment donné
font une pression plus aucun système
fonctionnel qui marche bien je veux dire
il y a un état qui fait des contrôles a
priori c'est la Suède
ça n'empêche pas d'exporter il y a un
état qui fait du contrôle a priori mais
plutôt en matière dissuasif c'est les
États-Unis et là c'est très concentré il
y a deux ou trois staffers de
parlementaires américains qui s'il
commence à dire à l'état-major et à des
mystères de la défense attention à ce
sujet pourrait poser problème
immédiatement on se met en situation de
négociation entre l'exécutif et le
Congrès donc ça c'est intéressant
l'Allemagne pour moi c'est très
caricatural c'est à dire qu'en gros il y
a un grand débat ou une bonne partie de
la des partis politiques notamment à
gauche et chez les Verts dire on est à
fond contre et de toute façon ça passe
quand même ça n'a aucune importance les
augmentations se font quoi donc c'est
c'est un débat qui n'est pas documenté
de mon point de vue ou les sujets droits
de l'homme sont très présents c'est très
bien mais où les sujets stratégiques
n'existent pas en Allemagne le débat
militaire et armement c'est un débat
dans lequel il y a droit de l'homme d'un
côté et de l'autre côté business à aucun
moment il y a la politique
internationale qui intervient et ça
c'est quelque chose qui ne correspond
pas du tout à la tradition française et
qui rend peut-être un peu difficile le
dialogue parlementaire franco-allemand
sur le sujet alors il nous resterait peu
de temps mais j'ai vu qu'aujourd'hui le
droit international comment ça a changé
pour dire que les industriels sont aussi
responsables de l'usage que leurs
clients font des armes qui leurs ont été
vendus est-ce que c'est la réalité
est-ce que la responsabilité des acteurs
industriels cette fois oui bien sûr on
peut être mis en cause
des fameux traités internationaux qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure bien sûr et puis
regarde le droit national enfin il
serait quand même tout à fait
extraordinaire de considérer qu'un
secteur économique parce que concurrent
souvent été nationale échappe à toute
forme de responsabilité pénale ça
n'existe pas ce n'est pas possible donc
on est dans un cas de figure assez
étonnant en France même cascaïen c'est à
dire que on a un état qui refuse en
quelque sorte de rendre compte et d'être
redevable devant la représentation
nationale sur ces exportations d'armes
on a des industriels qui nous disent
nous ne sommes pas responsables c'est le
premier ministre qui délivre les
licences à l'exportation donc celui qui
délivre les autorisations exportations
les industriels ne sont pas responsables
ceux qui fournissent ces équipements et
les parlementaires jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à preuve du contraire étant ça
sera encore le cas tant qu'une
délégation une institution Adobe c'est
pas au sein du Parlement pour contrôler
les parlementaires les parlementaires
disent bon c'est quand même un sujet
compliqué et puis c'est le rôle de
l'exécutif d'ailleurs monsieur Cambon
qui propose cette délégation cette
extension du pouvoir de la délégation
émotionnellement le répète dans les
motifs de son amendement dans le cadre
de la LPM c'est le pouvoir exécutif qui
est responsable des livrets et les sens
alors non d'une part l'État est
responsable il doit respecter le traité
sur commère des armes la position
commune de l'Union européenne les
industries de l'armement ont une
responsabilité celle de s'assurer qu'ils
ne vante pas des armes qui peuvent
servir à commettre des crimes de guerre
et l'affaire Lafarge montre à quel point
le juge français
évolue je fais un parallèle dans cette
affaire là le juge finalement dit il
n'est pas besoin que celui qui a
corrompu est donné de l'argent
à daesh et une intention de participer
au crime réalisé par daesh et donc c'est
une forme de jurisprudence qui peut
avoir son importance sur la question des
ventes d'armes parce que quand on vit
des industriels de l'armement et c'est
le cas en France devant le juge pénal et
je m'arrête là ceci peuvent être
reconnus potentiellement complice dans
la réalisation des crimes de guerre on
s'est rendu compte après coup
semble-t-il que 25 pays auraient
alimenté et vendu des armes à daesh au
final vraiment ça sera tout mot de la
fin vous souhaitez réagir mais vraiment
pour dire que moi je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec avec aymer c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une espèce d'impensée dans
l'industrie française qui commence à
vraiment je dirais à évoluer maintenant
c'est on n'est pas protégé par la
licence et un juge judiciaire je pense
que le juge administratif Conseil d'État
mettra du temps avant qu'ils mettent en
cause la responsabilité du gouvernement
qui signe de décret ou la licence en
revanche n'importe quel juge y compris
pénal y compris à l'étranger et ça
commence à arriver puisqu'on a eu des on
a eu des contentieux impliquant des
boîtes étrangères non italiennes devant
un par un juge italien et donc c'est
juste judiciaire là peuvent
effectivement considérer que il y a une
responsabilité pénale de la part
d'entreprise et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'elles doivent prendre en
considération ça serait le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat autour des
vents armes et notamment des ventes
d'armes françaises et le manque de
contrôle le manque de transparence
concernant justement ces fameuses ventes
d'arbres vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débadoc sur Twitter je compte
sur vous pour réagir à ce que sont ces
réactions merci à Selma Sally qui comme
à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission merci aussi à féliciter Gavalda
qui pendant six mois nous a elle aussi
aidé à préparer cette émission et je
voulais saluer son travail à cette
occasion prochain rendez-vous avec des
Badoc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]